hello everyone and welcome to the most
prestigious event of the year or uh
barriet of every other year as it's uh
event that takes place every other year
that we have the Canada tournament and
then we have the next year the
worldshire championship it is Yanni Palm
Machine versus Ding lyron and uh this
year it's uh a little bit different
because we don't have uh the actual
world champion defending his title uh
that would be Magnus Carlson Carlson
decided not to play the world's
championship event he's either skipping
this cycle or has given up on it all
together uh we still don't know but
that's a topic for for a different time
here we are focusing on this uh first
game of the world's championship match
uh Nepal versus ding now as this is the
first game I'm gonna give you some of
the information regarding this uh event
and uh I think that that's going to be
enough but if you have any questions uh
regarding the players themselves the
format of The Watcher Championship
pretty much anything uh do you do put
some questions in the comment section
below and I will answer it at the
beginning of the uh of the second video
so the tournament is being held or
rather the match is being held in
Kazakhstan in Astana this is the venue
it's the Saint Regis Hotel very nice
place as you can see
and it will take place over the course
of 21 days from 9th of April to 30th of
April which is kind of different because
uh uh well before you had two rest uh
two rest day uh sorry uh two two days
playing and no three days playing and
then arrested in three days playing and
then rest day now we have two days of
play Then rest day two days of played an
arrest day and it takes um a bit longer
and another thing that's very important
is that we will not be having 12
classical games instead we will have 14
classical games uh which makes it all
the more interesting and there's a
higher probability that we will get
um uh the wheelchairs Championship
decided In classical time format uh not
unlike you know the previous ones where
pretty much every all of them uh were
decided in Rapid time for me the last
one decided In classical time form it
was when Magnus defeated vishwanta in
2013 and also okay in the rematch in
2014. but ever since
um that we only had we had this decisive
games like in the cross and kayaking
match but not really anything decided in
the classical time format so that's uh
that's different so
um I'm very much looking forward to that
I think Magnus was looking good to make
it shorter than that he wanted to
include the lower time formats if he was
the to defend his world championship
title but this is what they're going for
uh for now so uh like I said uh it's not
a world champion versus Challenger but
in fact the winner of the candidates
tournament Yani polishi who absolutely
demolished the competition in the
previous candidate tournament versus
England who placed second in the
candidates tournament I I believe he was
behind the nipple by a point and a half
which is huge but okay it did it did get
him a seat at the wheelchair
championship match and if you haven't
seen their game at the the affili candle
this tournament do check it out uh we'll
be first link in the description below
they play two games of course one was
the the first game of the candle
instrument where nepo absolutely crushed
the dingler and in a uh in a true
Brilliance it was a miniature I'm sure
you guys have seen it in case you
haven't maybe it would be a nice
preparation in uh you know before you
check out this game and their head
head-to-head score it's fairly close uh
I believe Jan won three games uh ding
won two games and eight games were drawn
so basically that the one brilliancy was
uh uh the the tie breaker in inian's
favor but now of course 14 more games of
classical chess before we decide on what
to do next uh in order to win the match
of course you need seven and a half
points as 14 games will be played uh and
uh as it says on the official uh page of
the world's championship match if you
know a winner is decided then we go into
playoff the price fund is 2 million
euros uh split 60 to 40 percent unless
we go into tiebrex then it's 55 to 45 uh
percent no draw offers are allowed until
after move 40 and each players has each
player has 120 minutes for the first 14
moves then 60 minutes for the next 20
moves and then 15 minutes at the end of
the game with a 30 second increment
starting only for move 61. so this is
very important and I really love this
thing about the World Series
championship match so you don't have
increment all the time you only get it
only if you reach move 60 once you hit
that move 61 that's the first time you
get increment because the players would
pretty much draw every game uh 100 if if
it was the other way around this way it
is possible for you to go into time
trouble and if it's a crazy position you
will have two to three options maybe to
choose from you will you or rather your
chances of blundering do increase so so
I think this would will make it a more
action-packed World Series championship
match uh but you know it's still remains
to be seen and a playoff will consist of
four 25 minute games with a 10 second
increment starting from move one if
still tied up uh to uh up to two pairs
of five plus three games will be played
if tied again single three plus two
games are being played with colors first
EG game until one player's player wins
so uh the world championship match will
most certainly not be decided by an
Armageddon game so that being said uh
let's check it out and if you guys are
interested okay here's a nice photo of
the
of the venue here is the the first move
being made uh by uh I don't know who the
gentleman is if you guys know do sure in
the comment section below and here is a
sort of a wider angle uh just so you can
enjoy the venue before we check out the
actual game so that's it let's check it
out uh it's nepo uh who has the first
move and he opens the game with Ponte E4
there were a lot of uh different uh
speculation on uh with a nipple would
would go D for c for maybe he would go
for the reti uh or or something else but
uh E4 it is for the first game and this
ding is mostly an E4 E5 player I'm sure
he doesn't mind this and that he's very
well prepared for it so he goes spawn to
E5 Knight to F3 Knights the C6 and the
bishop to B5 the rui Lopez is on the
board with A6 morphe's defense and the
bishop to A4 we have Knight to F6
castles and Bishop to E7 and here you
might think okay it's not a very
exciting
um uh you know a choice of opening for
for the first game of the World Chess
Championship match but already here on
the next smooth we don't have rookie one
which is the top move in the position
nor do we have D3 which is the second
top move in the position actually we we
have a very very uh cool move order
Bishop captures on C6 we have D captures
the reason why B captures on c6s and
played is YB captures on C6 isn't played
in pretty much any of the line point is
that now after Knight captures and
Knight captures let's say Rook D1 you go
back Knight to F6 and now uh D4 and now
let's save Castle uh C4 can be played
and now you will always have problems
here you cannot play D6 or D5 because
that pawn on C6 will be hanging so this
Pawn here uh is just weird and if you
play C5 you allow D5 so white will
always get a little bit of something
there so that's why after Bishop
captures on C6 you know even though it's
a general principle to capture towards
the center you capture away from the
center in this particular instance and
now just Rook the E1 uh of course uh
just nicely continuing here Knight
captures an E5 would be it would be
sub-optimal move because Hereafter
Knight captures Rook D1 there's always
the annoying Queen to deform which
forces you to make silly moves like
Knight to D3 to defend and so on Bishop
F5 and already uh black is uh enjoying
this game very much so instead after the
captures on C6 we have Rook D1 just
nicely continuing the game and now we
have Knight to D7 it's a sort of a
Berlin type question how do you defend
the E5 Pawn whether you go Queen to D6
or you play Bishop to D6 or you play
Knight to D7 or you pin the Knight with
Bishop to G4 here we have Knight to D7
and it took ding some 10 minutes that um
I made this move basically with the
first thing of the position up until
this point they just made moves and here
nepo strikes with the D4 it's a move
that statistically brings white to the
uh the biggest chance of of actually
gaining something more than a draw he
captures we have Queen captures nicely
centralizing going after the G7 pawn and
here at dink castles with Bishop to F4
which will always put that nasty
pressure on that uh C Pawn which is
doubled uh and now Knight the C5
offering a queen trade and while you can
definitely trade Queens here we have
Queen back to E3 and already you can
feel that the nipple is starting to
create something here The Black Queen is
still on the eight if if uh if Nepal can
get Knight to C3 and Rook 8 to D1 and
could be very very unpleasant if the
Knight moves maybe the queen comes to G3
you can have a lot of pressure against
that black king and uh ding definitely
did start the burn time because Nepal
was still at like an hour and 57 minutes
on the clock ending was already to an
hour and 37 minutes on the clock so down
20 20 minutes which could be very
relevant later on and um uh it's uh
basically the the first real Improvement
this was also played in the bond that vs
Smith love game from 1946 and uh Queen
to E3 is is the improvement over that
game so uh of course Nepal prepared very
well and here we have Bishop to G4 now
the real question is do you go F6 the
the counter the the Knight here and to
prevent the five digital Bishop to G4 or
Knight to the E6 and I will quickly show
you Knight to E6 as this is a World
Series championship game so I will show
a line or two uh extra uh than I would
in a regular video the point is that
let's say Bishop to G3 and now you
continue with B5 C5 and so on let's say
y continues Knight B to D2 upon to C5
rotate to D1 a very standard stuff and
now uh black will have to move the queen
at some point Knight to H4 you want to
grab that F5 Square Bishop to G5 you can
attack the White Queen let's say queen
E2 and now Bishop to B7 so it's a
position that would probably arise maybe
through this move order maybe through a
different move or the white will gain
the access to the F5 square and the ding
will after some calcium relation uh
probably play G6 and now the point is
there's this very nasty Knight to F3
move and now absolutely everything gets
traded off and it's a force to draw for
example G captures and F5 e captures an
F5 now attacks the Knight also puts
pressure on the bishop here Knights the
F4 you can trade Queens Rook captures
Rook Queen captures Rook captures Knight
captures on G5 let's say Knight captures
on G2 Rook capture 78 Rook captures and
now let's say F3 threatening to pick up
the Knight but just H6 and now after
King captures and G2 H captors and G5
you will pick up that C7 pawn and now
the G4 uh uh preparing to to win back
material here let's say Rook to d8 uh
offering a rogue trade uh and now you
can play G captures and F3 check King
somewhere wherever Rook captures Bishop
captures and everything gets traded down
into a completely drawn end game with
Bishops of opposite color so Knights the
E6 would uh yield something like that so
ding instead plays Bishop to G4 and it
is only now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so not nice the E6
has been attempted here Bishop to G4 uh
wasn't and now uh Nepal placed Knight
the D4 and it's a very very tricky move
now uh he's saying that he doesn't want
to give Dean the option of trading
Bishop for Knight also he wants to be
able to bring the queen to G3 also F3
might be an idea in some lines because
you don't want that Bishop guarding the
one you want to develop the Knight and
play Rook 8 to D1 to attack the black
queen so those are some of the ideas
behind the movie sorry behind moving the
Knight and also if the bishop ever goes
let's say to H5 you will gain access to
the F5 square and here we have Queen to
D7 by nipple and this is a very very
important decision because there are a
couple of other good options Bishop
sorry Bishop to F6 one of them Knights
the E6 the other and queen to D7
seemingly the third one
uh I'm just gonna show you why uh
they're interesting so if you go Knight
to the E6 okay let's say we just trade
Knight captures the bishop goes back
Knight to C3 now Rotator D1 is coming
and you can play something like let's
say Bishop D6 but after rotate to D1
black has a very easy Choice here and
that is Bishop captures and F4 you just
offer a queen trade of course white does
not want to trade queens and then you
play Queen to E7 which is perfectly fine
for black now you don't have to play
Queen to E8 you you've connected your
Rooks your queen is on a very natural
square and the game just nicely
continues tonight the East is definitely
a viable move the other one being Bishop
to F6 kinda asks for E5 and if E5 then
bushes back to E7 and H3 now trying to
win that F5 Square for your knight uh
you can play this in between Knights the
E6 and I decision to
um going after the D4 Knight and now
after Knight captures an E6 you're just
gonna win back the the a piece with the
bishop Knight the C3 now preparing Rook
a to D1 and here you will have to play
Queen to E8 but then later on you can
play some like B6 C5 maybe even Queen to
C6 connect your Rooks and get your
pieces into the game so those are all
very very playable options dink however
plays Queen to D7 and it's a very very
different uh move order than what we've
discussed because now uh do you have
time for Knight to C3 and Rook 8 to D1
so it's a very very
a a very interesting uh topic uh because
it it is of course um possible and if it
is possible you should definitely go for
that and Nepal calculates that it is
possible he plays Knight to C3 and now
comes Rook a to d8 and the question is
how do you continue here uh uh what move
is is there the of course you have to
defend somehow against the queen captors
knight uh but there are many moves to
try here you can bring the Knight back
to F3 you can bring the Knight to B3 you
can bring the Knight to F5 you can play
so many uh interesting moves and there's
one that uh I don't know if nepo
considered or maybe even had prepared
but there was the very very tricky Ponte
H3 move the reason why probably it
wasn't played uh because after Queen
captures on D4 you don't touch the
bishop you're actually playing Knight to
D5 that's the that's the tricky part now
threatening Knight captures Bishop with
check and now after Bishop captures um
and now after removing the bishop with
Bishop to F6 you will play Knight
captures on F6 and now after G captures
an F6 Queen captures on D4 after root
captures you we're gonna play H capture
Sun G4 and now you get this position
we're okay it's a bit of a tricky Pawn
structure for both white and black but
let's say after Rook captures I need for
Rook captures Knight captures Bishop
captures on C7 you get this position
where it's um equal material black has a
doubled F Pawn white has a double G Pawn
but it is a bishop against the Knight
and with play on both sides of the board
uh uh nepo's Bishop would be much much
stronger so the point is that after H3
you can't really play Queen captures on
D4 and the main move to consider here is
Rook F to E8 now the difference is
Knight to D5 will not be a threat as the
the bishop is defended and now after
Queen to G3 going after the C7 Pawn now
you play Queen capture Sandy for Bishop
captures and C7 and now Rook the C8
chases away the bishop Bishop actor E5
now attacks the queen and queen to B4
but now the problem is there's really
not all that much to do here you can
play 3 and if Queen captures some B2
which of course you will play now you go
under the mask of the bishop Knight to
D5 and now Queen captures and C2 Queen
captures and G4 threatening Checkmate
Here and Now Knight to E6 defending
Knight captures and E7 will win the
bishop Rook captures and now Rook 8 D1
and uh you sort of win the win the D
file for for yourself uh it's a very
tricky line okay you're down a pawn but
you do have immense pressure on on
Black's King and uh you know it's uh
it's something definitely worth
considering uh if you are looking for uh
for Advantage but uh it wasn't played in
the game Knight the F5 was played just
getting then I thought of Harm's Way and
also asking are you maybe interested in
capturing an F5 and um it looks like it
is possible but the problem is after
Bishop captures and E captures you don't
really have this because the bishop here
would be hanging so Rook after E8 and
now the idea probably what everyone
thought was Pawn to F6 and it would be a
beautiful Pawn sacrifice uh because you
can't really take it g captures is just
weird because it opens up the the black
King for free the bishop cannot capture
because of Queen captures Knight the
Knight would hang so you'd have to play
Bishop to f8 and here there is a
spectacular Line featuring a queen
sacrifice F captures and G7 Rook capture
7 E3 uh G captures an f8 with check
promoting to a queen Rook captures and
now Rook captures on E3 and you would
have um a very very interesting game
because of the the dark Square bishop
and The Rook uh you know being joined in
such Harmony the problem is after Rook
to E8 there's really no good way to make
this work for example Rook to G3
checking the h8 and now Bishop to H6
looks wonderful full but Rook just comes
back to G8 and you don't really have all
that much of Rook D1 of course you want
to get the other Rook into the game as
well Queen E7 now trading doesn't really
do anything for you you will not be
having Rook to d8 you can play Rook to
F3 and okay the the tension uh remains
uh it's it's a very tricky position
where uh a queen has been traded for for
a rook and Bishop and you probably don't
have enough compensation but you know
it's it's very interesting you have to
check what happens so okay after this
Knight to F5 move of course Bishop
captures was not played instead we have
Knight to E6 uh uh of course the Knight
was coming here all along it was merely
a matter of time attacking the bishop on
F4 and now comes Knight captures on E7
again uh there was this uh Ponte H3 move
that is uh very interesting but again
look at this bishop to C5 attacks the
White Queen and after Queen to G3 Bishop
captures an F5 and now a nice in-between
move Rook 8 to D1 but again you allow
black to give up the queen queen
captures on D1 Rook captures and now
Rook captures with check Knight captures
and now Bishop captures an E4 and again
okay white is up a queen but the bishop
pair here is is incredible The Rook if
it's able to come into the game it's
gonna be
it's not going to be easy defending this
luckily you have Bishop captures on C7
and you prevent Rook to d8 so that is
going uh you know wide's way but still
The Bishop's pair is just uh spectacular
here so even though you could win the
black queen you don't really you don't
really want to play this I don't know at
least the end didn't so here instead
Knight captures on E7 Queen captures and
now Bush will be back to G3 to get rid
of this tension Knight captures on F4
will no longer be an option and now
Bishop to H5 now dink has to decide how
to how to do this does he want to play
F6 does he wanna does he want to strike
with F5 maybe for example captures
captures also a possibility but this
makes uh things a bit too interesting
and maybe in Black's favor opening of
the f file so uh objectively White
should always be better but maybe it's
giving black a bit too much so instead
Bishop H5 ding now wants to play F6 and
put a bishop back on F7 and now Pawn to
F3 we have Pawn to F6 and uh nipple says
all right you're not really doing all
that much I'm gonna make my position
even more safe I'm gonna play H3 and
King to H2 ending says I'm gonna do
exactly that and then ding plays H6 we
have King to H2 and now Bishop back to
F7
uh the problem is uh you could continue
uh with something like Queen to B4 but
like we said it's uh capturing on B2 is
never really a good idea for black if
you play Queen captures on B2 uh there's
uh even the the huge threat do you even
see the huge threat here that's um uh
the the great question why is this a bad
move feel free to pause the video and
try to figure out this hypothetical
position while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh finding this
beautiful queen crap and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop captures on C7 so
congratulations to everyone who found
that the the way to find this is that
okay of course you're gonna ask
yourselves uh what do we play uh if the
The Rook just attacks the queen well the
C2 Pawn will will hang but what if we
play Bishop captures on C7 then the
problem is after Knight captures on C7
you have this beautiful Rook to A2 move
which uh if if you just played the
before playing Bishop captures on C7 the
queen could go back and the pawn would
be protecting the queen that's why you
give up a piece in order to uh make the
B6 Square unusable for the black queen
and here you would just uh win the black
queen and the game so that's the problem
uh but you know a a very nice idea you
might think okay I I you know I fixed
everything in the center I have no
weaknesses on the king side I'm just
gonna play Queen before and win a pawn
uh you know like that ever worked out
for anyone but okay Bishop back to F7
and now we have a very nice idea and
that is uh Rook to D1 uh so instead of
Bishop to F7 okay Dean could have uh
maybe decided to double Rooks on the D
file but you know of course that uh
you're not gonna be owning the default
or anything because the white will just
be rotate the D1 and nipple will be able
to trade Rooks whenever he wants so here
B6 and now Pawn to A3 another move to
consider is F4 because you of course
want to play this at some point but this
bishop to H3 now just looks very odd
yeah you force The Rook to move you can
either capture and then all of a sudden
the D file might become the ding file as
you're going to lose control over it so
instead just spawn to A3 we have Pawn to
A5 by ding probably with the idea that
um the pawn on E6 does not become a
target for example if if a nicer look
the D3 lift is being played if Rook
captures Queen captures then the A6 Pawn
might become a Target in some lines so
that's why upon the A5 and now we have
Knight to E2 and here there's actually
another beautiful line uh that we have
to explore because a lot of people
actually thought it was possible that it
uh shows up on the board and that is
Knight to D5 now the problem is you have
to capture there is really no no good
Square for the queen here so let's say C
captures Pawn captors now you can't move
the Knight because the queen would hang
but there's Queen to C5 luckily the only
good move for black and now D captures
an E6 Queen captures an E3 Rook captures
on d8 there's always um time to capture
on F7 so you don't have to rush Queen is
still being attacked so Queen to G5 and
now e captures an F7 with check King
captures an F7 and now Rook to D7 check
King to G6 if you go King to J then
there's also the the rookie 4 could be
very nasty so King to G6 but now Rook e
to E7 you go after the G7 pawn and after
Rook to Jade Rook captures on C7 and you
really don't hope uh not achieve
anything here with uh with black I mean
you have a queen but your Rook is stuck
for the rest of the game Guardian G7 so
it doesn't look like something you
uh you can win the engine says it's
perfectly fine I might even favor the
position a little bit for black probably
because the black queen can gobble up
maybe some pawns here on the queen side
and then create some some pressure but
it really doesn't look like something
that you'd willingly play like imagine
if imagine if you play rooked F7 and
then the bishop ends up on okay on f8
not really I mean it's still possible
you can always get like two Rooks versus
a queen uh so you know not something to
look forward to uh but okay uh it was uh
it definitely was possible but okay
Knight the EQ is what nepo decided to go
for and uh yeah okay also F4 uh pretty
much the the same idea here if you if
you capture will capture Sun D1 uh then
uh Rook capture Sandy one and Bishop to
H5 uh again asks pretty much the same
question okay you can play Rook to D3
but then Knight the C5 all of a sudden
and that Rook uh isn't really having the
the time of his life you know it's a
really really weird position even ideas
like maybe Rook to D4 Knight go another
Knight going back to D6 can be played
here so yeah you have to be careful you
know in order you know you're looking
for Advantage but you might draw the
game by four so here instead Knight's
day two was played and now we have Rook
captures on D1 Rook captures and Rook to
d8 offering a rook trade and you know
that the Rooks will get traded off at
some point but it you know it's now it's
a matter of who can last longer we have
Pawn to C5 and now ding is trying to
cover all of his weaknesses by playing
these pawn moves even though here you
are kind of giving nipple maybe three
squares for his Knight there so also
very tricky stuff uh Queen to D2
doubling up here now you can't really
move the Knight or the queen from the
defense of the Rook here and he's
basically asking for ding to capture on
D3
uh the situation on the clock is 50
minutes for Nepal and 30 minutes for
Ding and here we have Pawn to C6 uh just
uh you know grabbing more squares here
uh ding is now down to 18 minutes after
playing this move so he spent quite a
lot of time uh calculating this and nepo
decides to go for Rook capture Sandy
there's also another uh fun uh move to
consider here and that is Bishop to D6
which really looks like a move that nepo
would play uh now but it's a very hard
to calculate and Ling is already a very
long time so you don't want to allow him
more time but let's say a queen move
somewhere you can now play F4 and if C4
which is basically Black's only move
Rook to G3 and the character of the game
changes completely like maybe F5 is
coming then you're gonna have problems
on the king side but also if Knight the
C7 just E5 can be played and now if
cappers captures again you have problems
on the king side so a very very rich
position but nipple goes uh for after C6
for Rook captures on d8 uh it is in fact
the strongest move recommended by the
engine so Nepal not going for any of uh
the uh usual nipple moves uh and now
Knight captures on d8 this is much
better than Queen captures the problem
is after Queen captures the Knight
captures there's always this bishop to
C7 move uh yes by playing C uh six uh
ding removed this Pawn from being a
Target but once the bishop lands on C7
all of the pawns now become Target so
that's the problem uh with being Queen
side and it's something that he's gonna
have to figure out how to handle with
Knight capture 78 and now a quick Queen
F4 now with ideas of Queen turn I see
seven also Queen to be it in some lines
also just Queen to B8 or C7 followed by
Bishop to D6 in some lines and a lot of
stuff for linked to handle and he plays
the bishop and he plays Pawn to B5 which
is kind of your only move and the
problem is uh once he played it he had
13 minutes on the clock and he needs to
make 13 more moves to reach time control
so basically he's left with uh like a
minute for a move until the uh first
time control is reached you the problem
is if you play something like Bishop to
C4 which can be played let's say Knight
to C3 and now you try Knight to E6
attacking the queen there's Queen to B8
with check and once the king moves
there's B3 you challenge the bishop and
now what uh what can the bishop do there
really aren't all the many squares even
if King F1 uh Bishop F1 King can attack
it with the G1 so you have to go
somewhere like Bishop B5 but now Knight
captures C captures and queen captures
on B6 you win a pawn and these pawns are
now incredibly weak you will win them
all probably and then win the game
easily so that's why B5 had to be played
and now we have Queen to B8 now putting
pressure on the Knight so uh the king is
still on gated Bishop to C7 lands uh
it's a game over so Dean has to play
King to H7 and now comes Bishop to D6
and here nepo spent quite a lot of time
calculating this position because uh
it's probably the move that will decide
the outcome of the game uh do you want
to play Bishop to C7 to put pressure on
the Knight and win the A5 do you want to
play Queen to C7 trade queens and then
win the A5 Pawn or do you want to play
Bishop to D6 now the uh okay the
uh Bishop to C7 idea is uh is a nice one
so after Knight E6 the point is after
Bishop captures on E5 there's always
this nasty Knight the D form which
attacks the Knight and the pawn here so
you have to trade Knight capture C
captures and after let's say Bishop B6
attacking the D4 Pawn here you will play
C5 looks a little bit odd but um you
know it should hold whether or not the
nipple will be able to to exploit these
weak pawns is uh definitely a question
but at some point if you are able to
play something like C for D3 could be
good all in all objectively this is
better for white whether it's better or
much better that really depends on how
good you are but one thing uh you've
eliminated the a pawn which means at
some point B3 and A4 will create a pass
Pawn for white and uh you know long term
that will be that will be definitely an
asset okay another thing instead of the
immediate Bishop C7 you could play Queen
to C7 trade queens and now let's say
queen captures Bishop captures attacks
then Knight and the A5 Pawn the Knight
moves you will play Bishop captures on
A5 and now again Knight to the D4 the
same idea the Knight and the pawn are
attacked captured captures Bishop to B6
attacks the pawn and now you don't have
C5 because the queen obviously is not
supporting it
um uh so it's a king to G6 you will play
Bishop captures on D4 and now you're
gonna be up a pawn and pretty much all
of these lines where you capture A5 you
will be up upon but the problem is let's
say Bishop A2 King G3 Bishop B1 attacks
the pawn C3 and now Bishop C2 uh it's uh
here you're even up two pawns not one
Pawn but it's Bishops of opposite color
and uh you know chances are aren't very
high that you will have winning winning
chances
uh yeah weird thing to say but uh you
know what I mean so those are nipples
options uh regarding Queen to C7 and
Bishop to C7 however nipple decides
against it he plays Bishop to D6 he
figures this will give him the most
winning chances but the problem is ding
pretty much automatically played Queen
to D7 and now there's a problem if you
play Bishop captures on C5 which was
sort of nepo's plan there's Queen to D2
attacks the Knight and now after the
Knight moves you have Knight to E6 uh
removing the defender of the C2 pawn and
let's say you play Knight captures
Bishop captures you have this weird
position where okay uh White is now up
up upon but black queen is so active
gonna be able to pressure all of these
Queen side pawns and imagine this Pawn
this bishop coming to C4 and F1
pressuring the G2 Pawn the White Queen
will have to go back all the way to G3
and it's gonna be I mean okay you will
you imagine you put a queen and G3 you
put the bishop on a fade you can also
put some pressure on the black king but
it's not maybe a game you want to play
giving leading so much activity so
instead nepo played Knight to G3 we have
knighted the E6 by ding now the C5 Pawn
is defended and now Pawn to F4 by Nepal
and this is not an easy move to make
this is a move that nepo made
um probably due to ding being so low on
time I think was below 10 minutes on the
clock here nipple had some 20 minutes on
the clock and you could play C3 here you
could play C4 here C4 is also a very
nice move because of course uh B
captures on C4 will never happening will
never triple his pawns uh so C4 is an
option obviously A4 is an option you
could also try to try to get two pairs
of doubled pawns here which would be you
know the positionally band for black but
never played F4 and now F5 becomes a
possibility amongst other things so how
can ding play this he plays Pawn to H5
he wants to kick away the Knight with
Ponte H4 uh and here uh okay instead of
this there was also the possibility of
knights the D4 that we should discuss
the point Pawn is attacked and after C3
Knight the B3 to keep defending the pawn
and now let's say uh Queen to f8 to put
pressure on the C5 Pawn now you can even
play Queen T8 and now again you will win
the pawn here for example Queen captures
Bishop captures Knight to D2 will now
attack the pawn and also come to C4 to
put pressure on the B2 Pawn so it
doesn't matter black will be down
opponent or pretty much all of these
lines uh but the black will be uh able
to hold this most certainly
it's okay ding decided to go for H5
instead and now we have Pawn to C3 uh
now uh rushing with F5 isn't really all
that impressive because you have H4
that's the problem and that of course D
knew when he played H5 and now if F
captures an E6 you have captors with
check any Bishop characters and now you
will play Queen captures on E6 and now
okay E5 can be played but now let's say
C4 you never wanna trade here and then
after he captures G captures to keep an
eye on the E5 square and the game
continues but Bishops are of opposite
color uh not uh not much to be uh
looking forward to here so that's uh one
of the one of the options so instead C3
was played uh just a nice slow move uh
protecting the D4 Square from the Black
Knight and now we have uh
Pawn to C4 and here the situation on the
clock is 16 minutes for nepo and only
six minutes for uh for Dean we have
Ponte H4 and now Queen to d8 sorry Queen
to d8 finally offering a queen trade and
nipple has to make a very very difficult
choice if he trades Queens let's say
Capers captures and goes Pawn to F5 yes
he has a very nice position but Knight
the B7 let's say attacks the bishop
Bishop E7 and A4 and it's not uh not
easy to play this okay the the Knight
will definitely have some squares you
can play 92 Knight to F4 you will have
access to E6 the G6 the H5 Pawn could be
uh very weak but uh the Black Knight
will also have those things imagine the
night coming to to D3 then how do you
defend B2 there is really no way then A3
false then C3 Falls so if you try too
much you also give black too much so
instead Queen to B7 was played now comes
um uh Bishop to E8 as the bishop here
was attacked you could also trade let's
say queen captures Bishop captures uh
but I mean again you're giving white uh
way too much here the Knight has easy
way of coming into the game the black
king is very vulnerable the H5 Pawn is
hanging so not something you want to do
so ding defends the bishop Bishop T8 and
only now Knight to F5 so here instead of
just going straight for the end game and
uh picking up that A5 Pawn like we've
discussed nippo has created some sort of
a some sort of a madness here on the
board that dink has to solve uh he has
five more moves to play until reaching
time control and he plays Queen to D7 he
offers a queen trade Queen back to B8
and of course he repeats Queen to d8 he
says if you want to push you push but
I'm repeating moves and it's uh eight
minutes for for Yan and 3.14 minutes for
uh three minutes and 14 seconds for ding
which anishigiri said that it's a a pie
amount of time I thought that was very
very nicely said uh but okay nipple
wants to continue the game and he has
the trade Queen chapter 78 we have
Knight captures on d8 and now Knight the
D4 now also you could consider Bishop D7
let's say Knight goes back to B7 and
then Pawn to A4 uh but you know it's
merely a matter of choice none of these
are are better than the other it's
merely a preference thing it's all night
the D4 was played and now we have Knight
to B7 attacks the bishop Now Pawn to E5
and King to G8 you of course you could
capture but if F capture is going to
have captures and then maybe King to G6
again you will get the F7 square and it
will be hard to push and even if you get
the pawn all the way uh there's still
the bishop Guardian the light Square so
King the G8 was played now comes Knight
captures um uh sorry not night chapters
on C6 first king to G3 and now Bishop to
D7 uh and now how do you continue this
it's move 40 uh time control has been
reached and um it was um basically uh
the the best nipple could do this E5
move was played at a crucial moment on
move 39 and the ding had some two
minutes to solve this position whether
he wants to capture where to play Bishop
the D7 to capture to start the King
march in uh how to continue so he
thought it would be best to just play
King to G8 and not make uh any sort of a
radical decision here and then uh what
continued was uh just King to G3 if you
guys are wondering about Knight cat
instead of this movie if you're
wondering about Knight captures on D6 it
is possible but it's uh fairly fairly
close to winning for white because now
uh you you have to stop Knight to E6 the
C5 and this D7 Pawn push uh so you have
to play Bishop here to control the
Knight but now let's say Pawn to B4 a
count for some b4a count for some B4
let's say G6 and now Pawn to F5 is a
very very strong for white and you will
you will gain very crucial squares here
for for your king so it's not something
that you want to do especially if
something like G captures then these all
of these pawns are extremely weak and
white is just much better once the king
touches the df4 square those pawns are
uh very very easy to pick up then the
Knight picks up the F5 Pawn then this
Pawn will fall then this Pawn will fall
and so on at some point the black king
will have to decide between guarding the
pawns on the king side and protecting
against the past D pawn and you will
easily lose this game so that's the
problem uh so like I said King to Jade
biting now comes King to G3 bringing the
king into the game and now Bishop to D7
we have reached move 40 and an
additional hour is granted to both
players to be able to continue the game
we have Bishop to C7 uh and here just
Knight the C5 not worrying about the A5
Pawn Knight the C5 is the way to go
because you will well you will win at
least one of the pawns Knight the Knight
will come to D3 then you will put more
pressure on E5 and the B2 Pawn is very
weak so Bishop captures on A5 was played
King to F7 and now Bishop to B4
attacking the Knight on C5
uh Knight to D3 and now E6 with check
with Bishop captures on E6 Knight
captures on C6 and now Bishop to D7 here
uh although a lot of you are wondering
that and why not Knight captures on B2
this actually plungers the game because
Knight to d8 check wins the bishop as
the bishop controls the dark Square so
the black king has to move away from the
defense of the bishop uh but yeah I mean
it is possible for such a thing to
happen uh but okay uh Bishop to D7 being
uh being very very careful here Knights
the D4 and now Knight captures and B2 we
have King to F3 Knight to D3 and now
Pawn to G3 with Knight to C1 and here
King to E3 was played and he was in this
position and move 49 that nipple and
ding agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here the Bishops
are of opposite colors the material is
equal and there is really no way to to
push for this uh you could okay burn
more time and exhaust every possible
option but then again you don't know if
that go was in your favor or your
opponent's favor you don't know okay you
could be very confident in your stamina
and maybe you want to torture your
opponent for like two or three more
hours uh but okay maybe that's gonna
help your opponent more than it will
help you so it's something that uh we
might see from Magnus Carlsen I mean he
he is famous for you know turning every
stone and squeezing every stone for the
for you know even a glimpse of a drop of
water uh but uh you know it's it's hard
to say we remember the uh like the the
first game of the match uh between
Carlson and carwana which lasted like
almost eight hours uh so that was a
pretty intense but it this one lasted
like four and a half hours so not not a
bad one uh and the ding will have to do
some more work uh
on his preparation especially uh
regarding these lines as there are some
of the lines here that nepo could have
taken that could give him more advantage
and it would be very very tricky for
ding to continue like that H3 line that
we've discussed uh I mean uh he did burn
a lot more time and he showed that he
didn't really uh have everything
prepared but yeah if nepo found like H3
in in in in this position or in some
other positions uh could be very very
annoying for him if you remember the the
line that we've discussed Queen captures
and then Knight to D5 a complete Madness
I know but it is uh there's so much for
them to cover because this is only game
one there are 13 more games to be played
and now uh if nipple is to repeat this
uh this line and ding is to repeat this
line all of them have to have all of
these all of these lines uh prepared and
analyzed and it's just gonna be
uh absolutely incredible so yeah very
nicely done first game ends in a draw
one of the things that I uh was
interested in one once I saw what
variation they were playing okay it's a
nice Lopez and the bishop t7 with the
bishop captures on C6 uh it's a line
that was analyzed many many times like
it's been played uh
so many times throughout history but
with every New World Church Championship
cycle players are preparing with
stronger computers so even if you check
a line that was checked before now with
you know different approaches from
different players and players having
different seconds now even I don't know
if you know uh one of ding seconds is
arihad Rapport who is known for his
incredible aggressive style and his very
creative play so what lines did he
choose or maybe uh got the dink to pick
up for the world chest championship
match would also be a very interesting
thing to know but also what I wanted to
know is that what um software and
Hardware were the players using for
their preparation for the wheelchairs
championship match so just out of fun I
I went to check which country has like
the strongest super super computer
starts now the strongest supercomputer
is located in Japan and okay you
probably figure that and the fourth uh
strongest supercomputer in the world is
in China Russia is not even in the top
10 uh but um yeah okay super computers
are used to do very important things
like you know find cure for for covid
you know calculate uh how maybe to
predict earthquakes or how to avoid
being hit by meteor but maybe you know
for the World Chess Championship Match
they would you know give them access to
those super computers maybe to prepare
prepare some chess lines uh I don't know
so I I like of course they're not using
um uh computers of that strength but I
would be interested in also what what
they are using uh as they you know they
make it public of who their seconds are
uh I'd also be very interested in what
they were using to prepare for the
wheelchair championship match unlike
Magnus who refused uh reveal who his
seconds are until the very last day of
or basically Until the End of the World
Series championship match uh still we
have no idea why that is so but you know
he he just rolled like that uh but okay
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
that first game of the World Chess
Championship match between Yani polishi
and dinglieren I hope you enjoyed it
like I said if you have any questions
that you would like answered and put to
them in the in the comment section below
I will answer them uh in the probably in
the quickly in the beginning or maybe
even in the end of the second video but
I will uh you know have a portion for
that uh whatever you guys are interested
in so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed a bit of a longer one but
it is the World Chess Championship match
so I really hope you enjoyed it and I
will see you see you with the the next
one uh the game two starts tomorrow I
would like to thank uh Christian hymna
uh www walkthrough.com
and the James Cashman for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing with game two of the world
cheers championship match between Yani
pomnishi and the dingler uh see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day